An emotional,
illuminating and at times,
frankly, infuriating
hearing on Capitol Hill today,
focusing on the chaotic US
withdrawal from Afghanistan in 2021.
CNN's Kiley Atwood reports for us now.
A U.S.
Marine
who was wounded in that horrific
suicide bomb attack
outside the Kabul airport
testified that his unit spotted
an Afghan man that they believe
was the suicide bomber
spotted him ahead of time,
but they could not
get the authority to engage.
My body was overwhelmed
from the trauma of the blast.
My abdomen had been ripped open
every inch of my exposed body
except for my face to ball bearings
and shrapnel.
U.S.
Marine Corps
Sergeant Tyler Vargas
Andrews is now a double amputee.
He was one of the 35 service
members injured
when a suicide bomber attacked Kabul
as the United States was withdrawing
from the country.
13 service members died that day.
There was an inexcusable lack
of accountability and negligence.
The 11 Marines, one sailor
and one
soldier that were murdered
that day have not been answered for.
The 25 year old shared his story
with the House
Foreign Affairs Committee
as they investigate the chaotic
and bloody U.S.
withdrawal from Afghanistan.
Hours before the attack, Vargas
Andrews used his sniper gun
to spot a man in the crowd of thousands
who looks like
the suicide bomber
that intelligence officials
had warned was in the vicinity.
He showed the man to his team leader.
We asked him if we could shoot.
Our battalion commander
said, and I quote,
I don't know and quote myself
and my team.
We were asked very harshly.
Well, who does?
Because this is your responsibility, sir.
He again replied
He did not know but would find out.
Vargas Andrews never got an answer.
He told lawmakers that the Navy
and the FBI
failed to interview him
about his experience.
Plain and simple, we were ignored.
Our expertize was disregarded.
No one was held accountable
for our safety.
He's not the only U.S.
service member
who is haunted
by the memories of that day.
Here is former combat medic Aiden
Gunderson screams from little children,
women and groom
and echoed in the tight corridor.
Marines and corpsman around me
through tears to provide
lifesaving aid to our motionless
and severely injured
American brothers and sisters.
Over the next hour,
I tried to save the lives
of countless Marines.
We all try our best.
It was a nightmare.
Some witnesses
blamed the Biden ministration
for the evacuations failures.
Good afternoon.
Others widen the aperture.
This is not the story of a Biden failure
or a Trump failure.
This is a story of an American failure
and the effect it has had
and continues
to have on Afghans
who served alongside myself
and so many others.
Multiple witnesses were U.S.
veterans who set up unofficial networks
to help Afghans escape the country.
They said they got requests
from high ranking U.S.
government officials
to help them get people out.
Me. US.
Private citizens
receiving requests
from our own government
to assist what is essentially
a governmental function.
It was humbling.
It was terrifying.
It was at times stupefying.
Now, one of
those who
provided testimony today, Jake,
warned of a mental health tsunami
for the veterans who were involved
in trying to get out Afghans
who they had actually worked
with in Afghanistan
and just talked
about how challenging that was
and how hard it was on them
when they weren't able to get out.
Some of the folks that they worked
with in the country
of course, today
we didn't see any Biden administration
officials providing testimony.
But we do expect that this committee
is going to be seeking out
that testimony.
From administration
officials down the road.
This is just an investigation
that is only beginning.
And presumably this testimony
that was provided today
in in addition to documents that the
they are trying to get from
the administration are going to be
what will drive
the questions
for Biden administration officials
when they do provide testimony Jake.
All right, Kelly, I would thank so much.